Don't slow down.
Well, that's -- [laughs]
Obviously he's trying to play very fast,
but when you want to play fast,
the first thing you have to do is relax.
Hi, my name is Antonio Sánchez.
I'm a jazz drummer and composer.
I'm a four-time Grammy winner,
and I did the film score for "Birdman."
Today, we're going to be
looking at drum scenes
from films and TV and
judging how real they are.
Are there any drummers in the house?
I play percussion.
Just see if you can do what I do, OK?
Just give it a try.
[laughs] The main thing to notice here
is they only have a
snare drum, a floor tom,
which is basically not
even half of the drum set,
and then the crash. It's
a kind of small cymbal.
There's no bass drum,
and there's no hi-hat.
This is the "School of
Rock." You need a bass drum.
It's, like, the heartbeat
of the whole thing.
So those are really not at all
the elements that you would need
to do a good rock groove.
OK!
So far, the kid is doing a good job.
Because he's doing what he told him to do.
The main challenge for somebody
that's coming from classical percussion,
to play drum set,
it would be how to coordinate
your feet and your hands.
Classical percussionists
don't use their feet too much.
Good. OK. No, that's bad.
That's like "George of the Jungle."
Play it up here on the
cymbal, but really light!
Aw, that's it. OK. Let's go!
Musically, I don't think
it was the right choice.
The song he's playing is
Deep Purple's "Smoke on the Water."
What you need in that
song is a big back beat.
[imitates drums]
And, again, he doesn't have
the bass drum and the hi-hat.
So I would have him maybe try to imitate
the bass drum on the floor tom, like,
[imitates drums] something like that.
Having said that, I know Jack Black,
he's a good musician.
And, you know, what he told
him to play, he did play.
I give it a 9 or a 10.
One thing that I noticed
right off the bat,
he looks relaxed. And
he's hitting hard, too.
He's hitting as a rock drummer.
That's not easy to do.
It's kind of easy to get injured
if you don't know what you're doing.
He definitely put some work into it.
Everything so far that I've seen
totally matches with what I've heard.
For example, in this section,
I can hear a double bass drum,
which, in this case,
you would have a pedal,
it's called a double pedal,
that has two beaters that are
hitting the same bass drum.
And then you play it like
if you had two bass drums,
but you're only playing on one.
And to me, it sounds like he
would have a double pedal.
So you can hear the
[imitates hitting bass drum]
from the double bass drum
and the hands just doing the cymbal.
It doesn't sound to me
like they're trying to
focus on a groove or a specific tempo.
It's more like an energy.
So she's screaming and
he's playing fast and loud,
playing around a tonal center,
and making sort of a wall of sound.
Like, almost if they're playing free,
and that seems like the right choice
for that particular tune.
I would give it a 10.
It impressed me how well he played
for him not to be a professional drummer.
Don't slow down.
I'm just not sure what
the drummer is doing.
Obviously he's trying to play very fast.
But when you want to play fast,
the first thing you have to do is relax
instead of tensing up.
That's why you have to
start practicing slow,
so that you can feel the movement,
how everything works together,
the right hand with the left hand
and the left foot and the right foot,
and then you start speeding
up little by little.
But just looking at the faces he's making
while he's playing, it was
like if he was lifting weights
and trying to see how much
he can go before breaking.
The body is one thing,
but if you start getting
tensed up in your head,
then that's the beginning of the end.
Pick it up!
Faster!
I didn't hear the song, but traditionally,
"Caravan" is not a very hard song to play,
and it's not a very fast
song to play either.
For example, there are other songs
that are traditionally very fast.
There's one called "Lover,"
and the melody goes [humming]
[humming].
The drums are supposed to play
kind of double time on top of it.
"Caravan" is not one of those.
"Caravan" is usually a medium up,
which is [humming].
Although I didn't hear the arrangement.
Maybe if they had an amazing arrangement
that justifies the song being
that fast, you can do it.
Whatever it is that he's
doing, it's not music.
I don't hear any real tempo.
I don't hear a clear pattern.
When you're playing jazz
at a very fast tempo,
you start usually with quarter
notes on the ride cymbals,
which is 1, 2, 3, 4; 1, 2, 3, 4.
Then the right pattern,
which is the quintessential
jazz bepop pattern,
which is what makes it swing,
is 1, 2, 3, 4; 1, 2, 3, 4;
ching, ching, cha-ching, ching, cha-ching.
We don't have a hi-hat today,
but that would be going in two and four.
1, 2, 3, 4; 1 2, 3, 4.
That's the basic pulse.
And then on your left hand,
you would be just kind of conversing
on what's going on with the music.
And then you speed that up.
But nothing he was doing
was relating to that.
There's no pulse, there's no
finesse, there's no nuance.
It's just like, kshh,
like a broken washing machine.
[cowbell ringing on tempo]
That's the pulse. That's
what he should be playing to,
but you would hear both
of them intersecting.
And to my ears, they're really not.
If you want your drummer to play
[imitates faster drumming],
you would not play that.
But the cowbell's a great instrument too,
to play really loud so that
the drummer could hear it.
Faster!
Well, that's -- [laughs].
The amount of blood that there
is on the drums right now,
that's kind of staggering.
The only times where I bled
is I hit the edge of the hi-hat.
You can open one of your
knuckles a little bit.
But that amount of blood on the drums,
that's a sign that something
very bad is being done.
I would probably rate it at a 1.
It kind of shows that speed
for the sake of speed,
there's no finesse, there's no nuance,
so there's no music, really.
My shoulders and my neck hurt
just by watching him play.
I remember this guy. There
was a famous clip going on.
He was doing all that stuff.
I remember watching
it, and I was laughing,
because it looked so crazy
but he sounded really good.
To me, it's very hard.
Because I've always emphasized trying to
make the least amount of movement
and get the most out of the sound.
And he's doing the most amount
of movement he possibly can.
Having said that, he plays great.
The grooves and licks
that Steve is playing,
they're fairly complicated.
A lick is basically a
pattern that you learn
that you can throw at any given moment.
So if you do [imitates drumming],
that's one lick.
Well, Kevin didn't
necessarily play any drums.
He just hit the cymbal a couple of times.
And that's it.
You can tell he's never really
played a drum set in his life,
which is fine. I think
that's the idea of the scene.
Twirling, throwing sticks up in the air.
They're not necessarily
connected to the music,
but if you want cool
visuals and showmanship,
they can be very effective.
When you do those kinds of tricks
and the music suffers because of that,
then I think you should
reevaluate what you're doing.
10, for sure.
Everything they're trying to
demonstrate that he's playing,
he's doing it.
It wasn't that bad.
That's a very simple drumbeat.
When it comes to drumming styles,
there are some that are
inherently easier than others.
Rock is usually where you start
because it's one of the most simple ways
to create already, like, a cool beat.
If you're going to do [imitates drumming],
that already sounds good.
Anybody with decent hand-eye coordination
could probably pull that
off in a day or two.
It's not totally lining up
with what you're hearing.
Movies, for some reason,
they usually don't get the syncing
with the image and the
music really well done.
Drums is very precise.
With guitars or bass,
you cannot really tell that much
because there's not that clear attack,
as when you are trying to hit something.
I mean, she's kind of doing it.
The technique leaves a lot to be desired
because she's grabbing the
sticks so in the middle.
You get no power from that,
because all of the weight
that you would be able
to hit the drums with,
it's not there.
You need to find the place in the stick
where it will bounce by itself the most.
If you hold it really far back,
it would just go like
[imitates sound trailing off]
and just die out.
And if you're holding really
to the front of the stick,
the stick would bounce and
then kind of fall back.
So you have to find the sweet spot.
And usually the sweet spot is, like,
three-quarters back into the stick.
In that situation, the drums
would sound really puny.
You can totally look that relaxing
and play a good rock beat.
Drummers, it doesn't matter
if they're jazz or rock,
they should be relaxed.
Usually rock drummers have a
little bit more of an attitude,
a lot more kind of big gestures,
even if they're doing something
simple, like she's doing.
Instead of playing on the hi-hat,
she's playing on the floor tom.
So [imitates drums],
which is like The White Stripes.
That's what they would be known for,
that kind of a beat.
I would say probably a 7 or an 8.
She didn't do such a bad job.
So, that's one thing.
Many people maybe don't know
exactly what it's called
or why people play this way.
What he's playing here is
called traditional grip,
which takes a lot longer to learn.
When you play traditional grip,
these two fingers are
kind of not doing much.
You have to find different ways
to make these two fingers
do the work of all these four fingers.
And then you're doing
it with your weak hand,
which is the left,
in terms of like he's doing
it or the way I do it.
So then you have to work twice as hard
to get some of the same finesse and speed.
When you think, why don't both hands
just do exactly the same thing?
That's called match grip.
The traditional grip comes
from the old marching bands.
People would play this way so that
there was an incline on the snare drum,
and then it was very easy to
play right here by your side
while you were walking or marching.
I think his playing
showcases the fact that
he's coming more from a jazz background.
Usually, people that play traditional grip
come more from jazz.
Sounds good.
What he started playing,
[imitates drumming],
was totally accurate for that time period,
in the '60s, and '70s too.
Like, for example, The Beach
Boys had a lot of songs
that had that kind of vibe.
That would be very similar to the kit
that Ringo Starr would
play with The Beatles.
It's a four-piece kit, they call it,
so, yeah, it's accurate.
He sounded good, and it
felt good. I think 10.
That's 100% accurate.
The first thing you would
do when you sit down
would be just to hit
everything a couple of times
just to see what it sounds like.
And then you would probably start
with some kind of groove
or couple of fills.
Depends also what style
of drumming you like
and what you play.
But if you were going to play
rock, that's pretty much it.
That would have been my
dream drum kit back then.
In the '80s, this was a thing.
For example, Rush, Neil
Peart had a gigantic kit.
This drum set is in what
they call a cage, which is,
it's, like, a metal bar that
goes around the drum set
where you set everything on top,
which was very popular during the '80s.
But what I notice is that
he's just using the left side of the kit.
Normally, your right leg would
be on the right bass drum.
And I know Dana Carvey, he
actually plays the drums,
and he's absolutely playing
everything we heard.
Drum solos can be anything.
You can have a completely
prepared drum solo,
or you can completely improvise
what you're going to do.
So there's really no correct
or incorrect way to play a solo.
Usually, in a rock context,
that's fairly accurate,
but you kind of keep some
kind of pulse happening,
and then you do a bunch of fills.
And it's just kind of meant
to get the crowd going.
What he did is not particularly hard,
but it's not particularly easy either.
You need a couple of
years under your belt.
But the drumming itself
is definitely real.
10, for sure.
Lately, my favorite drum movie,
even though the plot is very sad,
is the "Sound of Metal."
Everything you see
gives you the impression
that it's actually happening.
Thanks for watching.
And if you enjoyed this video,
why not click on the video above?